REPORT WITH BRET BAIER.
>> Bret: THIS IS A FOX NEWS
ALERT, AND I'M BRET BAIER IN
WASHINGTON.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL SAYS THEN
FBI DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY WAS
INSUBORDINATE DURING THAT
HILLARY CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION.
THE REPORT ALSO REVEALS A TEXT
MESSAGE IN WHICH ONE
INVESTIGATOR TELLS ON FBI LAWYER
THAT THEY WILL STOP DONALD TRUMP
FROM GETTING ELECTED.
BUT THE REPORT DOES NOT DIRECTLY
ATTRIBUTE POLITICAL MOTIVES TO
THOSE ACTIONS.
JUST MOMENTS AGO, THE CURRENT
DIRECTOR OF THE FBI PROMISED
THAT PEOPLE WILL BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE, BUT INSISTED
NOTHING IN    IN THE REPORT IMPG
NOTHING IN    IN THE REPORT IMPS
THE INTEGRITY OF THE BUREAU AS A
WHOLE.
WE HAVE EXTENSIVE COVERAGE
TONIGHT INCLUDING REACTION FROM
TWO CHAIRMAN, TREY GOWDY AND BOB
GOODLATTE.
BUT LET'S BEGIN WITH CATHERINE
HERITAGE AT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT TONIGHT.
LOTS TO DIGEST.
>> THE 500 PAGE REPORTS THAT IT
WAS 17 MONTHS IN THE MACON
ADDRESSES ALLEGATIONS OF
POLITICAL BIAS AND FOUND THAT
LORETTA LYNN SHOWED BAD JUST
DON'T MAKE A JUDGMENT AND FBI
DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY WAS
INSUBORDINATE.
>> NO CHARGES ARE APPROPRIATE IN
THIS CASE.
>> WHEN FBI DIRECTOR JAMES COMEY
GAVE HIS STATEMENT, THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL FOUND COMEY
WENT OUTSIDE THE CHAIN OF
COMMAND WHEN HE INTENTIONALLY
KEPT HIS BOSS, ATTORNEY GENERAL
LORETTA LYNCH AND HER DEPUTY,
SALLY GATES, IN THE DARK.
THEY FOUND IT WAS EXTRA NERI AND
INSUBORDINATE FOR HIM TO DO SO,
AND WE FOUND NO REASON FOR THE
DEPRESSED WEEKS OF BASIS FOR
DEVIATING FROM THE ESTABLISHED
POLICY.
IN A TWEET TO, COMEY RESPONDED.
I RESPECT THE DOJ IG OFFICE
WHICH IS WHY I URGE THEM TO DO
THE REVIEW.
THE CONCLUSIONS ARE REASONABLE
EVEN THOUGH I DISAGREE WITH HIM.
PEOPLE WITH GOOD FAITH CAN SEE
AN UNPRECEDENTED SITUATION
DIFFERENTLY.
ON TEXT MESSAGES BETWEEN PETER
STRZOK AND LISA PAGE, MICHAEL
HOROWITZ FOUND IN A DOCUMENT
DOCUMENTARY OR POLITICAL
EVIDENCE FOR BIAS.
IN A RECENT FOX INTERVIEW, COMEY
SAID POLITICS PAID NO ROLE.
>> I WAS DEEPLY DISAPPOINTED IN
THEM BUT I NEVER SAW ANY BIAS,
AND A REFLECTION OF ANY KIND OF
ANIMUS TOWARDS ANYBODY, EVEN ME.
>> A TEXT MESSAGE RECOVERED LAST
MONTH SUGGEST STRZOK MAY HAVE
ACTED FOR POLITICAL REASONS.
IN AUGUST OF 2016, PAGE ROAD,
TRUMP IS NOT EVER GOING TO
BECOME PRESIDENT, RIGHT?
RIGHT?
AND HE REPLIED, NO, HE WON'T.
WE WILL STOP IT.
THEN TENS OF THOUSANDS OF EMAILS
WERE FOUND ON A COMPUTER.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL SAID
STRZOK DRAGGED HIS FEET AND NO
ACTION WAS TAKEN UNTIL TWO WEEKS
BEFORE THE ELECTION WHEN COMEY
REOPENED THE EMAIL CASE.
QUOTE UNDER THESE CIRCUMSTANCES,
WE DID NOT HAVE CONFIDENCE THAT
STRZOK'S DECISION TO PRIORITIZE
THE INVESTIGATION OVER THE
LAPTOP WAS FREE FROM BIAS.
BUT STRZOK'S ATTORNEY'S DISPUTE
THAT SAYING THE DELAYS WERE
CAUSED BY MISCOMMUNICATION.
ON THE JUNE 2016 ARIZONA TARMAC
MEETING BETWEEN ATTORNEY GENERAL
LORETTA LYNCH AND BILL CLINTON,
THE REPORT CONCLUDED LYNCH
SHOWED BAD JUDGMENT WHICH IS
TOOK THE MEETING AND FAILED TO
RECOGNIZE AND TAKE ACTION TO GET
THE VISIT SHORT WAS AN ERROR IN
JUDGMENT.
ON WHETHER THE CLINTON EMAILS
CONTAINED CLASSIFIED INFORMATION
WERE HACKED, THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL UNCOVERED ON
FBI REPORT WAS CONDUCTED AFTER
THE ELECTION.
THE CONCLUDED QUOTE CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION WAS COMPROMISED BY
UNAUTHORIZED INDIVIDUALS WHO
INCLUDED FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS OR
INTELLIGENCE SERVICES BY CYBER
INTRUSION FROM ACCOUNTS LINKED
TO CLIENT AND SERVER.
WITHIN THE LAST HOUR WE HEARD
FROM FBI DIRECTOR CHRISTOPHER
WRAY WHO SAID HE ACCEPTS THE
FINDINGS OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL AND
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT MISTAKES WERE
MADE AND SAID THERE WOULD BE
CONSEQUENCES.
>> THE REPORT DOES IDENTIFY
ERRORS OF JUDGMENT, VIOLATIONS
OF OR EVEN DISREGARD FOR POLICY
AND DECISIONS THAT, AT THE VERY
LEAST, WITH THE BENEFIT OF
HINDSIGHT, WERE NOT THE BEST
CHOICES.
WE HAVE ALREADY STARTED TAKING
THE NECESSARY STEPS TO ADDRESS
THOSE ISSUES.
FIRST, WE ARE GOING TO HOLD
EMPLOYEES ACCOUNTABLE.
>> ALSO DIRECTOR RAY EMPHASIZED
THIS WAS A SINGLE INVESTIGATION
AND A HANDFUL OF EMPLOYEES WERE